انخرط اكثر من الف موظف من مراقبي الحدود
المعنيين بفحص جوازات السفر في مطارات
بريطانيه انخرطوا الجمعه في اضراب عن
العمل يستمر حتى نهايه الشهر الجاري
للمطالبه بتحسين الاجور يتزامن الاضراب
الذي ياتي على خلفيه موجه غلاء تضرب
اوروبا مع سلسله اضرابات في المملكه
المتحده وفرنسا والبرتغال ودول اوروبيه
اخرى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
الاسباب التي قادت الى موجه الاضرابات
التي تجتاح بريطانيا وفرنسا ودول اوروبيه
اخرى حاليا وما مدى ارتباطها بالظروف التي
يواجهها الاقتصاد العالمي حاليا
وما يتداعيات التي يمكن ان تتركها ازمه
التضخم على الدول الاوروبيه وما خيارات
هذه الدول للتعامل مع هذه الازمه واثارها
المستقله
[موسيقى]
وما مدى امكانيه تمدد تاثير التضخم في
الدول الاوروبيه على اقتصادات الدول
الناميه وعلى اي نحو ستتعامل حكوماتها مع
تاثيرات هذه الاسئله
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا
الشهر المقبل وذلك بعد ايام من عودتها من
اضراب اخر
الاعلان عن الاضراب المصنع يتزامنوا مع
انفراط اكثر من 1000 موظف من مراقب الحدود
المعنيين بفحص جوازات سفر المسافرين في
مطارات بريطانيه عده للمطارده بزياده
الاجور في ظل موجه غلاء غير مسبوقه تعاني
منها البلاد
الذي يستمر حتى نهايه الشهر وينتظر ان
تهبط خلاله اكثر من 10,000 رحله في تلك
المطارات يواكبه اضراب اخر بدائه الضباط
المرور في الطرق السريعه في لندن واجزاء
اخرى من انجلترا يوم الخميس على ان يستمر
اربعه ايام
بريطانيا ليست الدوله الاوروبيه الوحيده
التي تجتاحها موجه الغلاء وبالتالي سلسله
الاضرابات التي تسببت بتعطيل قطاعات حيويه
عده تلك الدول في البرتغال تعطلت حركه
القطارات يوم الجمعه في اول ايام اضراب
لعمال السكك الحديد بسبب التضخم وارتفاع
الاسعار
في فرنسا حيث ينفذ سائقون ومراقبنا وعمال
في السكك الحديد الفرنسيه اضرابا عن العمل
للمطالبه في تحسين اوضاعهم ورفعي هجورهم
شركه السكك الحديده الفرنسيه قالت ان
المئتي الف مسافر تاثروا بسبب الاضراب عقب
الغاء قطارين فائقي السرعه من اصل خمسه
قطارات بينما اعلنت النقابات الغاء
الاضراب الذي كان مقررا الاسبوع المقبل
تزامنا عوده الفرنسيين من اجازات راس
السنه وذلك بعد توصلها الاتفاق
على الحكومه
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من لندن كيف
الخبيره الاقتصاديه في مركز الدراسات
السياسيه والمستشاره الاقتصادي السابق
للمفوضيه الاوروبيه ومن واشنطن معنى
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
عن اسباب هذه الاضرابات التي تشاهد
بريطانيا
اوروبيه هل السبب هو التضخم وارتفاع
الاسعار واحده
وليد
العمال يحاولنا حمايه مع مستويات معيشتهم
بالمطالبه باجور اعلى ولكن اعتقد الامر
اكثر من ذلك فمثلا هنا في المملكه المتحده
وفي نجران نصف مليون شخص غادروا القوى
العامله خلال السنتين لمرضيتين معظم هؤلاء
قد يكون في الخمسينات او بدايه الستينات
من اعمارهن وبعد اقفال الكوفيت حصلنا الى
حوادث قياسيه من الناس يعانون من اعراض
المزمنه ومن المشاكل الذهنيه وعقليه وبدا
هذا تغير
لانها هقول لك كثير هاقول للناس
بان عليهم ان يعودوا الى القوى العامل لكي
يحافظ على مستويات المعيشهم لكن الامر
يتعلق بخليه من الاغلاق اصلا اثناء
الجائحه وايضا المشاكل الكبيره التي نعاني
منها بسبب التضخم المالي وبالتالي هذا في
الواقع هو الوضع حاليا بشكل مختصر
لنسال عن التضخم واسباب هذا التضخم هل له
علاقه همم فقط بالحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اما ان له ايضا امتدادات اخرى
اشرت الى كوفيد والى همم ازمه همم كانت
تظهر بوادرها ازمه اقتصاديه عالميه سابقا
كروشيه
الاساسي
[موسيقى]
المركزيه والحكومات بدات تصدر اعداد كبيره
من الاموال في هذه العمليه ما يسمى
التخفيف
الكميه وهذا يعني انا قيام الاصول ارتفعت
بشكل كبير فمثلا الاسعار المنازل في
المملكه المتحده ارتفعت بيها معدلات كبيره
جدا في السنوات الماضيه ولكن الان بدات
تنقف فضه والسبب
الحكومات بدات ترفع معدلات الفائده وبذلك
محاوله للسيطره او لتهدئه المعدلات التضخم
العنصر الاساسيه الاخرى اشرحها هي ان
الحكومه البريطانيه ما حكومات اخرى في
قاره اوروبا
يحاولونها اقناع المستثمرين خاصه الذين
يستثمرون في سندات الحكوميه
بان لانهم مسؤ السيطره على اجور الخدمات
العامه وتشاهد ذلك بشكل واضح مع وزير
الخارج ورئيس وزارتنا الجديده السيد سونا
الذي قال اليوم في الصحف بان عليه ان يدير
ويسيطر على الزيادات في القطاع العام في
الجوف في القطاع العام وذلك لتعزيز قيمه
العمله البريطانيه وزياده الثقه
المستثمرين في الاقتصاد البريطاني بعد
التعرض الصدمه كبيره
فقط لمده 44 يوما ولكنها تحصل على التقاعد
راتب تقاعدي
انتقل لك دكتور خليل العناني الى
نيويورك في الولايات المتحده الوضع في
الولايات المتحده لا يشبه ابدا الوضع في
الدول الاوروبيه اكان على صعيد التضخم
الذي اخذ ينخفض بصوره لافته في الاونه
الاخيره وايضا على مستوى سير همم
القطاعات العامه الموجوده في الولايات
المتحده يعني لماذا استطاعت واشنطن ان
تضبط الوضع الاقتصادي بهذا الشكل على خلاف
ما يحصل في الدول الاوروبيه
انا اعتقد ذلك العدد الاسباب او المتعلق
بالاجراءات التي اتخذها البنك الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي الامريكي والذي قام برفع متزايد
بشكل مستمر ومتواصل لسعر الفائده يعني على
الاقل خلال اخر 10 شهور هناك زياده حوالي
خمس مرات وصل ال سعر الفائده حوالي 5% في
امريكا وهذا يعني بشكل ابو اخر كبح جماح
تضخم وتزايد تقدر ارتفاع الاسعار سواء
ارتفاع اسعار الوقود نتيجه للحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا او ارتفاع اسعار المواد
الغذاء ايضا نتيجه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
نعلم جميعا انه اوكرانيا وروسيا تمد
العالم بما لا يقل عن 30 40% من القمح من
الشعيره من الزيوت الغذائيه وبالتالي هناك
رفع للفائده الامر الاول الامر الثاني
ايضا كانت هناك اجراءات استقباقيه فيما
يتعلق باضطرابات عماليه على سبيل المثال
قبل حوالي شهر من الان كان هناك دعوه او
كانت هناك دعوه لاضراب عمال السكه الحديد
في امريكا هذا يعتبر امر خطير جدا لانه
على الاقل 30% من التجاره في امريكا تمر
من خلال السكن الحديديه الداخليه في
امريكا وبال ليه تم اتقاد عدد اجراءات على
راسها على سبيل المثال قمر رئيس بيدن
بالطلب من الكونجرس الامريكي بتفعيل قانون
كان تم اصداره عام 26 يمنع عمال سكه
الحديد من الادراك وفي نفس الوقت توصل
اتفاق مع عماله مع نقابه العمال السكه
الحديد من خلال الاتفاق على رفع الاجور
حوالي 24% خلال اربع سنوات قادمه الامر
الثاني رفع الاجور بشكل حالي والي حاضر
14% او بالطريقه ده هذا ادى بشكل او باخر
الا عدم القيام بادراب همم قد يؤدي الى
شال الحياه التجاريه والاقتصاديه في
امريكا وبالتالي هناك اجراءات استباقيه تم
اتخاذها هناك استمرار مراقبه من قبل
الاحتياط ال- ال- بتوع الاحتياط الامريكي
فيما يتعلق بارتفاع تضخمه كما قلت استاذ
حسن
وان كان طبعا مرتفع بشكل كبير جدا مقارنه
ب 40 عام على الاقل ارتفاع تدخل في امريكا
حوالي تسعه بالمئه وهذا الامر غير مسبوق
على الاطلاق طبعا يظل الامر في اوروبا
اكبر من ذلك نتكلم على الاقل بريطانيا 10%
ارتفاع تضخم وهذا غير مسبوق على خلال
اربعه عقود الماضيه ههه
طيب للاشاره هنا مشاهدينا لان رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك عبر عن
السياقه مما سماها بالفوضى التي سببتتها
موجه لاضرابات الحاليه في البلاد وقلسوناك
انه يشعر بالحزن وخيبه الامل من اثار
الاضرابات على حياه الناس اليوميه مؤكدا
ان بابا مفتوح للمناقشات عن نقابات
المنظمه للاضرابات ووصف سوناك الاوضاع
بالصعده قائلا ان افضل ما يمكن القيام به
لمصلحه البلاد هو محاربه التضخم حسب قوله
نعود الى ضيفنا الدكتور كيف بوي فيلد من
لندن دكتور كيف هل بامكان بريطانيا هل
بامكان الدول الاوروبيه ايضا لن نتحدث فقط
عن بريطانيا في هذا المجال هل امامها
خيارات للتعامل مع ازمه الاضرابات وتاليا
مع ازمه التضخم وارتفاع الاسعار هل دي
مقدورها فعل شيء في هذه المرحله
حاليا
بريطانيا قد نشرت القوات المسلحه مثلا
للسيطره على الحدود في المطارات وفي
مطارات المختلفه والصحف تقول اليوم بان
الجيش يؤدي عملا افضل من الموظفين
المدنيين الاعتياديه اعتقد انك سوف
دعوات المتزايده للاستعانه بالمزيد من
المهاجرين وخاصنا الى المملكه المتحده
وهذه حقيقه
غريبه لان الان لدينا اعداد اكثر من الهرم
همم الاجانب حوالي ست مليون شخص
عددهم قبل خروجه من همم
لن نحتاج نستخدم عمال من الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكن ما حصل الان نحن نعين مستعين بالمزيد
من الاعداد الاكبر من دول كثيره مثل من
اسيا والشرق الاوسط ومن افريقيا فهذا قد
يصير استغراب بعض الناس لكن نظر لعدم قبول
الناس في الولايات المتحده بالعمل
والترددهم في العمل فاننا نزداد بشكل
متزايد على عمال المهاجرين ونقطه اخرى او
ضيفه وهي انه في فرنسا همم السيد ماكرون
يحاول ان يزيد علم التقاعد من 62 سنه لعمر
الحالي هو الاقل الى 65 سنه وهو يواجه في
ذلك همم
نقابات العماليه
وله حق ذلك
السياسين في اوروبا عليه في الواقع يعني
ان يعملوا اكثر همم
لانهم يعيشون زمن اطول والحكومه لا يستطيع
ان تتحمل وجودهم وبالتالي لابد ان نستغفر
يقترض المزيد الاموال ويفرض الضرائب على
المزيد من الناس لمحافظه على البقاع على
الاسلوب الحياه الذين اعتدوا عليه وخاصه
لمنهم فيه ما بعد 60 من العمر
هل يمكن بشكل او باخر ان تستفيد الولايات
المتحده من تلك الازمه التي تضرب الدول
الاوروبيه هل هذا وارد في هذا الوقت
ليس بالضروره ان نعلم جميعا ان هناك نوع
من الارتباط والاعتماد العالمي على كافه
الاقتصادات وبالتالي ما يحدث في اوروبا
يؤثر بشكل مؤخر على الوضع في امريكا اذا
اذا نظرنا على سبيل المثال الى حجم الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي العالمي في كلا من امريكا
واوروبا بنتكلم على حوالي 40 تريليون
دولار حجم او على الاقل 35 لترين دولار
نتكلم على 20 تريون دولار
ناتج محلي اجمالي عالمي امريكي حوالي 17
مليون دولار
ناتج اجمالي محلي اوروبي طبعا تاتي بعدهم
الصين الحلقه وبالتالي اي ازمه اقتصاديه
تحدث في اوروبا هي كلها دعايات شكلها باخر
على الوضع في امريكا خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالصادرات الاتحاد الاوروبي والذي يعتبر
شريك كبير لحد بعيد فيما يتعلق بالشراكه
مع امريكا والتبادل التجاري مع امريكا
وبالتالي العلام يقعد امرا او جزر منزله
هناك ترابط كبير جدا بين الامرين الامر
الثاني متعلق ب همم وهذا قد يكون جانب
ايجابي نوعا ما هناك امكانيه تقوم امريكا
بتصدير مزيد من الطاقه الى اوروبا من
تعويض النقص الروسي نعلم جميعا ان هناك
عقوبات اقتصاديه اوروبيه وامريكيه على
روسيا في ما تعلق بتصدير النفط هناك ايضا
قرارات تم اتخاذها خلال اربعه ايام بوضع
السقف اعلى لسعر الغاز الروسي في اوروبا
وبالتالي هناك حاجه اوروبيه خاصه بعد دخول
فصل الشتاء القارس ودخول موسم الاعياد
هناك حاجه اوروبيه لوجود مزيد من النفط
والغاز وهناك احتماد بشكل او باخر على
امريكا تغطي هذا النقص فيما يتعلق بصداره
الروسيه للغاز والطاقه الى اوروبا هناك
جانبي كان عنده هناك جانب سلبي فما يتعلق
بالاعتماد المتبادل بين الطرفين الاوروبي
الامريكي في الاقتصاد العالمي سيد كيس
اواد باختصار هنا انا اسالك همم الاضرابات
عموما في الدول الاوروبيه وتعطيل
القطاعات العامه وبالتالي مصالح الناس
وبالتالي ايضا دوره الانتاج ستتاثر الى اي
مدى همم هذه الاضطرابات تعمق همم ازمه
تضخم وارتفاع بدل ان تكون عامل ضغط لحلها
باختصار
ويدمر اقتصاداتنا في كل اوروبا وان
الانتاجيه همم في المملكه المتحده
وايطاليا
المسجد
سوف تطلع الى
مصادر بديله للطاقه من الطاقه المتجدده
مثل الطاقه الشمسيه والمزيدنا الطاقه
الهيدروجين وما الى ذلك وبالتالي في بعض
بطريقه مع اسعار الطاقه المرتفعه قد تكون
امرا جيدا لان اكثر حذرا حول طريقه
استخدامنا على الطاقه واعتقدنا الالمانيه
الالمان سيكون عليهم ان يعتادو
حماماتتين اكثر بروده
بيعتدوا اعتدوا على الدفن التدفيذ الزائد
او التدفئه الزائده بما انك اتيت على ذكر
الالمان همم المانيا ايضا همم رغم الازمه
الاقتصاديه لكنها لم تشهد حتى اللحظه على
الاقل اضرابات من هذا النوع لماذا باختصار
سيد كيف
الالمانيه فلديهم تقاليد قديمه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
بان الموظفين والعمال يعني تعاونو مع
ارباب العمل الحكومه وهمم
نوع من الاخلاص الكبير في المانيا لا نجده
في فرنسا همم فرنسا وبريطانيا احد المشاكل
في بريطانيا وفرنسا انه بعض قاعده اتحاد
النقابات العماليه هم الجاهل اليسار
المناضل مثل السيد الذي هو مسؤول عن
نقابه الخدمات همم المدنيه هو من ناحيه
السياسيه وعرض الحكومه وضدها هناك
انتخابات عامه ست شهد المملكه المتحده في
السنتين القادمه
الاداره الحاليه
يعني هنا هنا الحديث دخل في الجانب في
الجانب السياسي وسانقل همم
اود ان اسمع تعليق همم الدكتور خليل
العناني في في هذه النقطه هل لهذه
الاضرابات ان تحدث اضطرابات اجتماعيه او
ربما حتى اضطرابات سياسيه في الدول
الاوروبيه
قبل الشك استاذ حسن اي ازمه اقتصاديه يقول
لك دعايات سياسيه واجتماعيه وراين ذلك على
مدار الشهر الماضيه في الدول حتى خارج
اوروبا في سريلانكا وفي دول اخرى لكن بشكل
عام انا اعتقد اهم تدعات السياسيه لهذه
الاضطرابات وهذه الاحتجاجات وهذه لازم
اقتصاديه في اوروبا في العالم اولا تؤدي
الى زياده شعبيه المضطر في اوروبا والعينا
ذلك خلال الانتخابات الاخيره في ايطاليا
عندما وصلنا لاول مره في تاريخ ايطاليا
حرب عالميه الثانيه
حزمهم بشكل او باخر من الافكار الفاشيه
ايضا هناك صعود لان مضطرف في دول اخرى
مركزيه في اوروبا سواء كان في المانيا
سواء كان في فرنسا سواء كان في بريطانيا
او في النمسا اوبالتالي هناك بالفعل فمن
السياسي لهذه الاضرابات وهذه الاعتصامات
وهذه لازم اقتصاديه الامر الثاني ايضا
زياده الاعداء للمهاجرين هناك حاله من
صعود ازاي فوبيا او الخوف من المهاجرين
النتيجه الاعتقاد ان هناك نوع من
الاستيلاء من المهاجرين على الوظائف وعلى
فرص العمل وفي اوروبا وبالتالي هناك
بالفعل سياسيه قد تؤدي بعض الاوقات ولا
ايضا في بريطانيا على سبيل المثال عندما
يعني حدث تغيير لرئيس الحكومه قبل حوالي
شهرين من الان نتيجه ايضا لعدم نجاح رئيس
الوزراء السابقه في حل ازمه الاقتصاديه
وبالتالي هناك بالفعل ثمان سياسه هذه
المساله لكن في كل الاحوال ليست هناك ايضا
عصا سحريه حتى للبديل الذي يمكن ان ياتي
على همم انقاد السلف همم اعود اليك
باختصار سيد كيف الدول الناميه المرتبطه
بشكل او باخر تجاريا صناعيا مع الدول
الاوروبيه كيف ستتاثر مع هذه الازمه
ايضا هو ان ارباب العمل والمستثمرين الذي
يستثنون في هذه الدول مثلا في الهند
ماليزيا
واندونيسيا ونجى اذنا كثير مع الشركات
تنقل اعمالها الى الدول الناميه وبالتالي
فنجد ان كل الاحزاب لسيدنا على نظام
الديمقراطي الاجتماعي لا اعرف كيف سيعملون
في المستقبل لان نجد هناك
عبر العالم
بفضل العولمه
نستطيع ان نواصل ان نسدد اجور الناس
يتقاعدوا من العمر 62
كيف بوي فيلد الخبيره الاقتصادي في مركز
دراسات سياسيه والمستشار الاقتصادي السابق
للمفوضيه الاوروبيه من لندن اشكرك جزيلا
وشكرا للدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه الذي كان معنا
من نيويورك
لو هنا تنتهي حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]